Tesla is about to unveil its most
affordable car the model 3 this is the
big one the car that Elon Musk says will
take electric cars mainstream here's
what we know so far
we're expecting something similar to the
$70,000 Model S but with fewer bells and
whistles musk has said it will be about
20% smaller than the Model S and there's
no word yet on whether it will have the
distinctive oval front of the Model S or
the more tight-lipped mouth of the Model
X the model 3 will start at $35,000 but
that's before government incentives
which in the United States could easily
bring the price down below $30,000
that's an extremely competitive price
for the entry-level luxury market that
the model 3 will compete in Tesla is
promising at least 200 miles per charge
but it might be more especially for
people who are willing to pay a bit
extra for a larger battery Tesla is
designing a whole new battery
architecture to make the model 3 cheaper
and easier to do you on Moz predicts
that in the next 10 to 15 years all new
cars will be able to drive themselves
therefore you can expect the model 3
will probably come equipped with the
sensors for at least some autonomous
driving even if buyers have to pay a
little extra to activate them if you
want to get your hands on a Model 3
you'll have to get in line Tesla's gonna
start taking reservations with a
thousand-dollar deposit on March 31st
but the first deliveries won't come
until the end of next year